[Music]
[Applause]
talk about here so mike florio
mr pro football talk uh joining us on
the show where'd this come from mike
well what happens when you do
this for a living you end up talking to
a lot of different people you hear from
a lot of different people you hear
unsolicited things from certain people
and when i start to hear something over
and over again
from people in different universes in
that broader nfl
galaxy or it would be galaxies within
the broader universe either way they
know who we mean
either way the the uh the point is
when i start hearing the same thing from
different people who i believe
aren't churning the same stuff that's
when i start to pay attention to it and
i was very careful on how i wrote it
this isn't something that has happened
this isn't something that will happen
but there is a growing belief
that it could happen that deshaun watson
could say
i've had enough i'm out i think the head
coaching hire
is going to be a key piece of this
because they've made it clear dan
and deshawn has said this himself
they're asking his input on who the
coach should be
so if they ask his input and he gives it
and then i'll hire the guy
that he said i'd like to work with that
would tend to alienate a franchise
quarterback and the one thing that
fascinates me
yesterday shefty reported that eric the
enemy has already interviewed for the
other five
head coaching openings and he's not
going to be interviewed
by the texans how in the hell do you not
at least
interview the guy who's at the top of
everyone's list
i'm with you because i want to glean
some information from eric the enemy of
what kansas city thinks about my team
and i mentioned this last hour
you know this interviewing process it's
a fact-finding mission for a lot of
these teams because they'll go to
joe brady and go joe what do you think
of the falcons
you know you faced him a couple of times
tell us you may not give him the job but
you want that information there and at
least
you know the lowest uh part of this
is i'm going to bring him in or i can
zoom him and he can tell me what he
thinks of deshaun watson
j.j wadd what would you do with the
defense uh
wide receivers will fuller like those
are the things you want out of these
guys
it's the al davis approach that's what
he always did when he was hiring a coach
interview as many people as possible
it's a free opportunity
to pick the brains of your competitors
you know the panthers i've heard
somewhere between 20 and 40 gm
candidates they're going to interview
for that same reason it's a free
opportunity to pick brains now it could
be this day and it could be
that the enemy is a guy that desean
watson would want to work with
so if you go too far down the path with
the enemy
it's harder to say no so it's easier
to just never interview him than to
interview him and say to deshaun well
we we picked this guy instead of eric
the enemy wow
wow i got i'm trying to wrap my brain
around that one that
that you're not going to bring him in
because if you do bring him in and then
you don't hire him
is deshawn so is deshawn gonna be more
upset if you don't bring him in at all
or you bring him in and then you don't
give him the job is that what you're
saying mike
well right and this assumes that the
enemy is a guy
for whom desean watson would be stumping
but when you look at what the enemy has
done with patrick mahomes the past
couple of years a guy who was drafted
two spots before watson and if i'm
deshawn watson
i'm looking at patrick mahomes i'm
looking at josh allen i'm looking at
these other young quarterbacks and
saying
i'm as good as them if i was in kansas
city
we'd be the one seed in the afc if i was
in buffalo
we'd be on the brink of taking the
franchise to places it hasn't been
in decades how can i make something
happen here and i also
think that the aftermath of the bill
o'brien experience the patriot
connection
the nick casario hire if they hire a
brian dabal who's got some patriot dna
is that just too much for watson given
what happened
with bill o'brien the trades that were
made the dysfunction that has been
left in the aftermath of the o'brien
experience again
i'm not saying it's going to happen and
and maybe he's extra next level and he's
just
letting it be known that he's thinking
about it as that shot across the bow to
get the texans to take his preference
seriously
it could all work out very well but it's
out there
and it's a a subject of conversation and
i can't imagine that teams wouldn't be
lined up out the door
if there was an opportunity to get to
sean watson
you work for nbc sports football night
in america and drew brees
has a job there waiting for him um
are you under the impression mike that
drew brees is joining
the studio team next year dan
listen they only wake me up for the
unimportant meetings
i don't know what's going on and i
personally believe that drew brees is
going to be inclined to play again next
year if they have another one of these
close but no cigars i think it would
torment him for the rest of his life
if he steps out of football after four
straight years
of getting in shouting distance of the
super bowl having some sort of crazy
thing happen that causes them to lose
and he believes he's still physically
capable of playing the phil sims advice
to brett favre years ago was keep
playing until they ripped the uniform
off of you so i'm not sure brees walks
away
but i have a feeling the saints are
ready for him to walk away that's where
it gets
a little bit awkward they've been very
respectful to drew brees
sean payton a couple of times this year
has alluded to
the notion that brees won't be back next
year
and it may be the decision gets made for
him
i got verbally spanked yesterday by the
league office i had the audacity
to ask about kevin stefanski if there's
any way like what's the rule
leading up to the game any you know can
he be involved and then the league sent
back uh
an email saying uh why didn't you ask
about daryl bevel a couple of weeks ago
um you know and i my immediate thought
was well
nobody cares about daryl yeah nobody
cares and it's not a playoff game
and then he goes well the rules you know
we were told by the person in pr that
these are the rules they've been in
place the the people who coach
are there on site and they coach but it
feels like there's this ground swell
whether it's in the media nfl circles
because it's the browns kevin stefanski
and what a shame he's going to miss out
on a playoff game their first in 18
years so it's a big loss here but if
you're stefanski
what can you contribute to help baker
mayfield
once the game starts absolutely nothing
this is all information that would have
to be conveyed via zoom via meetings via
discussions
before the game there's no rule that
allows him
to to be there present with someone
holding up an ipad with a facetime hook
up where he's actually talking to baker
mayfield during the game those
electronic devices are all prohibited
for those purposes so he's out he's done
he can't be involved in this game
and you know i argue from time to time
that
a good head coach is worth more
financially
than a good player last week when we
were going through the
jared goff will he play won't he play
how good is he
i said you know if i'm going to give
33.5 million a year to jared goff or
sean mcveigh i'm giving it to sean mcvay
not jared goff i mean bill belichick
whatever he's getting paid nobody knows
what he's getting paid whatever it is he
deserves more
he's worth more other than a patrick
mahomes a short list
great player a great coach is worth more
and we're going to find out on sunday
night a playoff game
with mike preefer a special teams
coordinator running the show who's going
to talk to baker mayfield after he's
rattled by something
he sees in the secondary and and has a
mistake throws an interception or
almost throws an interception if he's
getting chased around by tj watt
who's going to calm him down that's
where we're going to see the value of a
head coach dan
uh job openings
the best and worst best is the chargers
by far
because they have justin herbert and
he's the real deal next is
the jacksonville jaguars because they
have the right to trevor lawrence
and we assume he's going to be the real
deal but i'll always take the guy
who shoney can do it at the nfl level
over the guy
who we just think can do it beyond that
dan and the jets i don't really know
what to think about the jets
i think the jets would be number three
because joe douglas the gm
is building the team the right way in
the trenches built from the inside out
not the outside in the other three jobs
frankly
lions falcons and texans
if i'm in demand and if i have options
i'm going to wait a year yeah because my
concern and this is a real concern among
people who are candidates for these jobs
it doesn't get talked about nearly
enough
you've got individuals in the
organization between gm coach
and owner there's another executive
there's another layer there it's rich
mckay in atlanta
it's rod wood and now chris spielman in
detroit it's jack easterby
in houston who's whispering to the owner
who's
undermining what i'm trying to do i want
a straight shot to the owner
i want to be able to communicate to the
owner not worry about what some other
executive who doesn't have the same
accountability i have
may be saying to the owner when i'm
inevitably going through a rough stretch
shefty had something yesterday or day
before about cam newton he was on a
radio station in boston but it comes
from shefty
it's not a report but he was saying hey
i could see maybe where cam could end up
with washington
and most of us had the reaction of gosh
i can't see him making that kind of
money
and then you realize well wait a minute
here is it news
because it's adam schefter saying i
could see him there
i can't imagine shefty going you know
what let me just throw this out there
without having some kind of backdrop to
this
so how do you what do you make of that
not report but that opinion
by shefty well i don't think it's
outlandish because of the history
between ron rivera
and cam newton you know we always assume
that if there's a past relationship
there's a presumption and a desire by
both parties to continue the
relationship
sometimes the past relationship will
cause people to say
no way in hell sorry been there done
that life's too short i don't want to
work with that person again
and what i heard yesterday was and i
think it got misquoted
i thought shefty was saying 40 to 50
million a year for cam newton
he was saying 40 to 50 million over a
two-year deal and
look i'd have to know how it's
structured i'd be very hesitant
to make a significant financial
commitment to cam newton without knowing
that he's more like the guy in 2015
than the guy in 2020 and
you know whether you do it with
incentives per game roster bonuses
i would not want to make a huge
financial commitment to him
now look the patriots got a steal 3.7
million for their starting quarterback
for the full year
even though they were seven and nine
that was a bargain he deserves more than
that
but between 20 and 30 million i i would
want
that to be based on what he does for me
and then he gets rewarded after the fact
not blindly paying that money going in
yeah i think shefty said that you know
incentive laden but i was also wondering
this
ron rivera gets there and could have
brought in cam
i don't know if because the owner said
no you're drafting dwayne haskins and
you're going to develop dwayne haskins
you can't have cam come in and bigfoot
him and say no no i'm the starter
you're not going to be i don't know if
that was
the line of thinking there mike but it
felt like ron couldn't bring in cam if
he wanted to
well think about this ron rivera arrived
as the head coach of the panthers the
same year
that cam newton was the first overall
pick in the draft and cam newton quickly
became the
face of the franchise and in some ways
bigger than the franchise and it very
well could be
that ron rivera has decided that's not
the ideal way
to build a championship team look that's
what bill belichick wanted to get away
from in new england with drew bledsoe
that's one of the reasons why he was
already thinking about
the shift to tom brady before mo lewis
blew up drew bledsoe
so you don't want one person to overtake
the team and it could be that for both
guys
cam newton and ron rivera nine years
together was enough
you got an upset pick this weekend that
we can make fun of on monday
rams that's an upset they're three and a
half point dogs
i'll say rams that's the only one i
think i think the other ones all win
all the favorites win we had orlovsky on
and he basically was guaranteeing that
jared goff's plan
oh you know what no i didn't pick the
rams i picked the seahawks i went with
the scratch across the board
sims picked the rams we both went back
and forth on the rams and seahawks i did
pick the seahawks
and i don't care if goff's playing goff
and john will it doesn't matter
golf like i said 33.5 million give it to
mcveigh
not to golf i'm still not sold on golf
what's his future there
well i when you look at the cap hits and
you know a lot of times teams will
double down when they're criticized for
giving too much money to a guy i think
they got a couple more years
where as a practical matter they have to
keep them around but if i'm sean mcvay
just like
kyle shanahan in san francisco and
shanahan should be there right now
i'm looking around at my options and
mcvay i think is
inching toward that point shanahan and
the 49ers should be there right now oh i
agree
i've said that since they got garoppolo
like
i don't get it but uh it felt like you
know even their game plan was not to
involve
a quarterback's arm uh which is pretty
amazing that you guys bob griese in the
playoffs last year
they he freaked shanahan out in the
second half of the vikings game when he
almost threw what would have been his
third interception of the day
there was only one interception that was
ultimately thrown and then they went
into
the early 70s dolphins mode until the
super bowl
where it was let's protect the offense
from jimmy garoppolo
it's and look the bigger concern i have
dan he gets injured too often
there's a point where you can't say well
it was bad luck here and it was bad luck
there at a certain point it's on you as
the quarterback
to stay healthy and be available to your
team what's the best thing that you have
to drink behind you
behind this is a wine cellar so it's
just wine i'm a big chemist guy do you
like kamus
yeah yeah i i gotta i gotta i got a
couple of suggestions for you if you
like camus i'm happy
please please i'm i'm more than happy to
hear any suggestions about wine i'm
still a novice in that regard let me
tell you this it reminds me of new
year's eve we had a very enjoyable new
year's eve
it was a two-kaymas bottle new year's
eve
and uh you know you have just on the
edge of a little bit i didn't have a
show the next morning so i could sleep
in i stayed up past midnight which gets
harder and harder as we get older
went to bed at about one o'clock slipped
into a very deep restful sleep
and at 1 56 a.m i got a happy new year
text
from todd fritz what are you doing
i'm sound asleep after a two bottle
famous knife i was hoping that wasn't
going to make some kind of noise or
vibration on your phone that i could
quite
wait are you being serious mike yes
pretty yes
1 56 a.m i don't know what time zone
he's dealing with it's not midnight yet
in denver
and it's two hours late yes in in the
eastern time zone i wanted to be the
first one to wish happy new year yes
my favorite part of that is that at 156
todd you were definitely not the first
person to wish him a happy new year and
actually you spent
you had spent two hours going through
your rolodex
texting everybody happy new year and
mike he finally got to you oh yeah
that's right
almost two hours later i just made it
under the two-hour window
you know that he didn't send it you
didn't send any of those to us i did i
don't like you guys floria i love i said
i could call him and two minutes later
he comes on the channel todd
todd you're allowed to love me less love
me at midnight i don't do that
i should have been more sensitive to the
times uh whose wife do you always text
yes that's accidentally because i keep
thinking it's joe's number and somehow
it's his wife's and how
all it takes is one time i somehow made
a mistake like three times
yeah i know he was a broncos cheerleader
yeah i know he's going to do with it
mike thank you
hey happy have a good week happy new
year